(gentle music)
- Can this be anything?
- [Thoraya] Anything.
- I think I'm scared to say, I love you.
I think I'm scared to say,
yeah how I feel about people, I guess.
I think I am not very good
at sharing my emotions.
So I definitely have a hard
time saying I love you.
I don't think I've ever been
in like a healthy relationship.
So it's like scary knowing
that you can tell someone
that you love them and they
don't reciprocate, I guess.
(gentle music)
- Telling my friends or like
in front of other people
that I'm, I don't know
I don't really have an answer for this,
but maybe bisexual.
Because I don't really,
I'm not a person that
needs sex in my life a lot.
So I kind of feel stupid to tell people
that I'm bisexual because that's something
that's related to sex.
And I am such an independent person
I don't see myself in a
relationship for a long time.
So I kind of feel stupid for telling them.
And a lot of people make
that your personality.
And I don't feel like this
is part of my personality.
It's just like part of my
life, but not a big part.
So I feel stupid telling people that.
If that makes sense.
- [Thoraya] It does.
What are you scared to say?
- Can I go whenever?
- [Thoraya] Yeah.
- Okay, so I think one thing
that I get really scared
or maybe like more so
nervous to say to people
is like I've been asked a couple
of times if I'm a Christian
and I get really like nervous
because I get put on the spot
and I feel like that's something
that's really important
in my life, but I get scared to share it
because of what people will like think
or like make assumptions about me,
especially just based off of like
what little they know about me.
People just don't realize that a lot.
So I think that's something
that I get scared to say
to people, even though I shouldn't be,
'cause that's really important to me.
- I am not happy (laughing).
- [Thoraya] Why are
you scared to say that?
- I guess, 'cause it
makes it, I guess real.
It makes sense.
- [Thoraya] Why do you
think you're not happy?
- I mean like look around,
there is a homeless guy over there.
And you know, you have all this,
you know wealth.
- I'm scared to ask for help.
And to admit that I need help
because I always feel like
I'm strong, I've got this.
I can do this easy, but
sometimes it'd be a lot easier
if I could just surrender and
let somebody else help me.
- I'm pretty scared to say
like affectionate things
to my guy friends.
That's definitely something
that I wish I could overcome
is like being able to show affection
as like person to person,
like guy to guy, you know?
- [Thoraya] Okay.
- Yeah.
- I wish the question was,
what am I not scared to say,
Palestinians lives matter.
What's happening today
in Gaza and in Palestine
goes against human rights.
And I wish we can
highlight that topic more
and bring more awareness
to the rest of the world.
But it doesn't matter whether
I'm Palestinian or American.
I feel like people should
side with the right side
and anything that goes
against human rights
is the wrong side.
To (speaks in foreign language) Palestine.
- Sometimes I'm scared to say the thing
that I really want in life.
To not share it is to not
rock the boat of circumstance.
'Cause to say that word
becomes like a new major
roadway of a left or right in life
it's like a new major ingredient.
Like if you're cooking
you've got like four major ingredients
and you're like, well, I
really want this in there
and that's gonna really change the flavor.
And it's all relational.
I'm thinking of that.
Being scared to say
something in a relationship
with someone, whether that's like romantic
or friendship or work and
to add a major ingredient
into the recipe just by the nature of it
really changes the future of the recipe
and what it'll taste like.
- Well I was scared to say anything
that would let people into my life
because I never really feel
like I'm good enough for them.
It doesn't matter if it's a
friend or romantic relationship.
Yeah, I've working really hard to feel
like I'm not inferior to other people.
It's been a crazy last year for me.
I like went through rehab
and I'm like staying
sober in Montana right now
and trying to get my life back together.
And with that comes, you
know a lot of self-respect
like understanding where I was a year ago
and where I'm at now.
Like I feel like I'm
getting closer to the point
where I can be honest with
others about where I'm at,
and feel like equals.
- I'm scared to tell people
that I'm not actually a successful
and smart as they think I am.
And I'm kind of showing an image.
My whole life revolves
around keeping up the image
and I'm letting people down
if I don't keep the image up.
- I'm scared to say the,
like the, the real things
going on with our society
and everything like that.
'Cause a lot of people, they
say what needs to be said
but then they get pushed
down for saying those things
even though they're true.
With politics, with religion,
with culture, we're all just people.
But like when we say like,
we love who we wanna,
we love who we wanna love
but we still get torn
down for those things
even when we speak out about it.
When it doesn't affect anyone else.
(gentle music)
- I am scared to say that I am a failure
and that I'm failing in my life
and in all the categories that describe me
whether it be a daughter, a student,
a girlfriend, a human being.
Yeah, I just said it
so I guess I'm not that scared.
But scared to say that.
- I'm scared say what I'm most afraid of.
To talk about my fears because I feel like
when you can talk about your fears
you unveil your insecurities
and that's always hard
to talk about or to face.
- [Thoraya] Would you be down to share
some of your fears right now, or?
- I don't know, I just said
it was the hardest thing
for me to say.
(both laughing)
That's when I shut down and I just like,
well I can't, like I lose language
I can't talk about anything.
- I'm scared to say what
I wanna do like in life.
And I think that's because
once I say it out loud
then people know
and then once you say it, people know
and they can hold you accountable
and then you have to
actually take action on it.
- I am scared to tell people
when they've disappointed
me because I fear
that they might not wanna
be my friend anymore.
- I'm scared to say no, like right now.
(laughing)
Honestly, I'm scared
to say no to anything.
It's such a terrible
feeling to let somebody down
and not give them what they're asking for.
- [Thoraya] So you were scared
to tell me no for doing this?
- Yes, definitely like
I was trying so hard
to think of something
and I realized that
that's, that's my problem.
So yeah that's it.
- [Thoraya] Oh man, well I appreciate you
doing it even though--
- Yeah absolutely, I'm
terrified right now.
- What am I scared to say?
Oh, it's a lot of s**t honestly.
I can't even think of it
on the top of my head,
but even my own family it's just like,
I mean it's traditional Asian household
like they want you to be a doctor.
Like I was doing human
bio for the longest,
I was doing like finished
my whole bio series,
physics series, chem series
and like, I was one semester
away from transmitting
and I was like, I don't
wanna do any of this.
And I feel like that's
just that realization
is just as valuable as
figuring out what I wanna do.
'Cause like what I don't wanna do.
I don't know I just find
myself as I'm getting older
I'm really finding myself
gravitating towards things
like I loved as a kid.
I used to really be into art,
little pieces of me wants
to keep going back to that.
That was a long-winded answer.
I don't even know if it was
the answer to your question
but that's just what--
- [Thoraya] No yeah it is.
- I just had to, yeah.
- [Thoraya] I feel like you
answered your own question.
- This is therapy, right?
Gave me a lot of clarity.
(gentle music)
- Everyone, quick announcement.
I decided to make a separate
channel for my podcast.
It's gonna be linked in to description.
The new channel is called Hey Stranger
which as you know is
the name of my podcast.
If you enjoy watching the
video versions to my podcasts,
make sure to subscribe on there
that would mean a lot.
I tried really hard not
to make a second channel
'cause I just didn't
want a second channel,
but it really made sense
for the podcast to have its own channel
'cause there are longer
videos and I'm in them.
And I'm usually not in my videos on here.
So I finally decided to
make the new channel for it.
I really hope you guys will
consider subscribing on there.
Again, it's linked in the description.
And yeah, so for my main channel
and back to my regular schedule
which is, I'll be uploading
every Thursday on here,
just like we used to
I'm back from my break.
And for my podcast, I'll be
uploading every other Tuesday.
So basically every Thursday on here
and every other Tuesday I'll
be posting my podcast episodes
on the new channel
that's linked in the description.
And then of course you can
still find the audio versions
of my podcast on all
the podcast platforms.
And yeah, that's pretty much it.
Thank you guys for everything.
I love you all.
I'm happy to be back and
I'll see you next week.
(gentle music)